hello everybody my name is Marc plan
welcome back to let's play slender haunt
all right so we got our ass handed to us
or I got my ass handed to me the silver
platter last game oh hi get out of here
I'm gonna walk backwards into you hey
that's not cool man what are you doing
what are you doing up there
wait don't up there yeah that's right
your stock ain't jump oh you're [ __ ]
screw you and everything you care about
I'm out here AB you man f off man
alright so ah he's coming after me get
away get away what are you doing what
are you doing he's like stuck on the
mountaintop I don't know what to do
about that anyway so I know exactly
where the pages are that I need to
before I can get into the factory are go
it's gonna do this for me back and forth
isn't it but if I'm walking you can't do
it can you your dick all right so I'm
gonna quickly I'll get the one from the
shed the poisonous plants and then oh
come on you're kidding you said you know
your name hole man okay I'm gonna
quickly get the ones from shed poisonous
plants haunted tree done
BAM out of here - thus the factory
there's actually a lot more leeway than
I thought getting near Slenderman but
not looking at him I mean yeah I mean
you saw right then and there that I was
pretty damn close to him but I did not
die all right let's hurry up seems to
have stopped porting me everywhere I
know that the shed is just off to the
east here maybe I'm gonna swing swung
everybody Wang Chung tonight
come on bring it on Slendy don't bring
it on bring on the page and I can do
other stuff
okay so aha bingo bingo Bongo hey f off
Slendy yes yes yes a screw you oh I'm
looking right at you whoops
okay so if I'm not mistaken I actually
don't have to run from him I can just
sort of gently walk if I'm not mistaken
you know like he does not seem to move
if I'm not looking at him so so long as
I'm not looking at him and I don't panic
I should be fine and that doesn't start
static King come on quickly here we go
all right
poisonous plants right in here rabbit
get out
[Music]
uh-huh right here instantaneous like oh
come on what about with that I turn
around he's already gunning for me you
and your wooden jacket damn it
screw you man screw you I am NOT going
to noob I'm gonna beat this on gamer cuz
that's what I is rabbi what am i oh no I
don't know man I'm just as lost as you
are I screw you you back up on the mound
again I'm not here oh you didn't care
screw you know how he like suddenly gun
for me out of the blue like that maybe
because I taught it him ah what up ah
he's such baloney baloney malarkey
[Music]
I was a weird sound I've never heard
that before
ah screw you oh hello hi man he's all up
in my grill scare anybody
what well am i fine screw it
I'm gone you can do about it Slendy man
[Music]
I'm gonna get this I am going to get
this
you guys are ah ah come on he's still
stuck what if I look at the ground no it
doesn't help it's about what all about
the facing come on stop hoarding me all
over the place and let me get from point
A to point B turn down the intensity
turn up the intensity down down up
it sounds like he's close that sounds
like a throbbing close ah what the hell
is going on here I'm dull under ah good
God who's not fair he was not like this
he was not he would not know what's
going on I thought I was a slender
professional but apparently I'm a
slender a wimp I don't know guys I
really don't know okay I'm just gonna
back up back to the F up
I hear him but I don't see him oh whoa
who's that oh come on stop doing that
where is he why am I so staticky what
housing over there stop porting me and
just oh god it's probably I'm building
up a lot of slender aggro because he
gets stuck in the mountain and I'm
looking at him see there he is again
God ported me back again I'm building up
like a lot of slender ego or something I
don't know like my safe might just be
giant pain in the ass for this because
from now on now that I've looked at him
so much he really wants me then again
[Music]
oh come on up I know you're stuck on a
rock again how about how about this go
[ __ ] yourself
[Music]
Oh put me off there it is this is this
is making me very upset I am cuz I mean
oh I had you know guys just wrong Oh God
ah I want to see the end of the game I
really really do for some reason it's
just like whenever I load up this
particular save game it's constantly
making him perma agro all over my ass oh
good okay
look it like a boss quick quick get in
and out in and out in and out in it up
no I'm not looking at you I see you on
the mound there but we're off where am i
where am I whop whop whop running
running where'd you go I was looking at
you what are you talking about I'm
looking I didn't see anything
screw you did not see a thing okay maybe
I made it out this time
but man if I don't make it in this
playthrough what I'll do is I will get I
will go back behind the scenes on noob
whoa where is he where where where I'm
not looking at him geez stop that
goodness gracious yes I don't make it
through on this episode I will go to
noob and I will get back to where I am
right now
[Music]
I don't know slender is a gigantic
[ __ ] in this game like bigger than I
remember
oh man what an a-hole but it's okay cuz
I am a professional that's not what who
knows okay there's this there's this
shed
what oh wow you piece mother
ah oh right there ah pretty go where to
go I was right there oh I was touching
it I was touching that thing
[Music]
no no don't do it again
Oh how are you done of a [ __ ] oh oh you
don't know the things I would do to you
Sonny
take your Pentacles reenact some
Japanese porn all over you alright there
it is does you got a coming it beat hub
barreling right for me huh is he good
alright just gotta get it from the pine
and I'll be OH
then I will have it to the pine to the
pine to the pine alright do not cross is
still the poisonous plants if I was like
in this direction so the pine taiga
angry there happens to the best of us
[Music]
I needed that my vodka
how did I get back to the cabin No okay
here's a sign greening is like right
there I did not though is that closed up
I now I'll just hop over this fence here
and be on my merry way so easy to get
turned around here
Simon's funny I'm okay
cuz I'm an intrepid explorer gee I
wonder why slender's left me alone for
so long it's almost as if he's gone
forever
haha
like that huh yeah that is the creepiest
tree in the world okay factory that way
but my first stop is back up the hill do
the same because I will save and I will
finish this on gamer gamer maybe I
should wait
since Slendy is up there I know the hill
the house is like right back there what
if I go back to the house huh I just
watch this really bad movie on Netflix
called zombies zombie zombies was about
um zombies and strippers of course but
it was like I usually do that where I
watch really really really bad movies
and I just laugh at how bad it was and
it was so stereotypical company he was
he was just - I had to bitch-slap
everything or pimp-slap
everything and he was always like Oh
Cole ha I'm gonna get it raw and he
actually prepared pin flapping zombies
orgy in the video this is the stupidest
thing ever hi no don't give me cheese
I'm almost to the house I'm almost to
the house where his house walls where's
house is right here I know it was three
quarters to the back end of the [ __ ]
it's three nil to the [ __ ] I don't
know
where am i where am I
where did I go how did I get here
where am i I got lost against Lindy's on
my
whoo turned into a goof come on this
always happens I get to this point and
then I'm like ah I hope I can save and
then suddenly lost forever never to find
civilization ever again cuz this is
exactly what happened last time I was
like I got to this point where I had
this many pages I was like dude save no
you get lost you go ahead and you die
the game sit that's made they've me I
feel like the game where the hell oh oh
ha green pine this very green in this
way here we go cuz somehow I missed it
this looks suspiciously like the way I
was just going you know you know how
that is hmm what is it
no no of course not wait was it this way
[Music]
come on
show me an outline oh flashlight of the
few universe aha guy get away from
exciting all right I just got to get in
this house in holy hell that is a
gigantic fly what is it's freaking
December why is there a fly in here I
don't care chefs Lindy's not gonna give
me aah
[Music]
oh yeah Oh
everybody with me Oh
oh did you do it I know when you don't
do it come on okay one more time do it
with me this time
oh okay so next time I get to go
straight to the factory and then I can
finally beat this game see it like a
botrytis but for a long time even though
there's not that many parts but anyway
so you will see the ending of the game
on gamer thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos to that time and as always I will
see you in the next video shut up your
help